welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and right out
the gate d23 has some amazing
announcements with more Marvel shows
being added to the Disney Plus roster as
well as a kit harington casting rumor
that sounds too good to be true now we
knew that Kevin Feige was holding some
stuff back at San Diego Comic Con
recently and I think it's pretty safe to
say now that he did have some tricks up
his sleeve at the d23 Disney Plus panel
the Marvel Studios president announced
that she Hulk MS Marvel and Moon Knight
would be coming to the streaming service
and that they would be essential viewing
for those who want to stay up to date
with the movies both Moon Knight and MS
Marvel have been rumored for a while
with brie Larson as strongly captaining
excuse the terrible pub there the latter
ever since her own solo movie Captain
Marvel launched in cinemas earlier this
year the incredible face for update now
means that the shows will feature
alongside the other following Disney
exclusives the Falcon and Winter Soldier
Loki and the mysterious what-if series
that will show alternate versions of
famous events from the Marvel Universe
whilst no dates have been announced for
the shows yet it is possible that they
could even lead into phase 5 and appear
in the latter part of the slate as a
bridge between the two lineups the
Disney Plus shows are set to be
essential viewing for Marvel fans with
Loki exploring what happened to the
character after he disappeared in
Avengers endgame and one division
showcasing how vision is brought back
from the dead can machines die I don't
know is it is it like when you buy a new
laptop I don't know anyway I'll show
Scarlet Witch gone to the computer
repair store to get fixed
I'd imagine for those who don't know
she-hulk is Bruce banners cousin and she
became the character after she received
a blood transfusion from banner that
transformed her this could be from smart
Hulk which would set why the character
is not a rageful monster as bar her
appearance and abilities there's little
changes about her mentally MS Marvel is
Kamala Khan who is Captain Marvel's
protege and she's the first Muslim
superhero to headline her own comic book
I definitely think this will be tied
together tightly with cap
Marvel and the two will probably appear
side-by-side in the show which will help
disturb Captain Marvel to Moon Knight
has been rumoured for months now and he
is a former mercenary and CIA agent that
has a split personality but carries the
powers of an Egyptian god
though the announcement of kit
harington's casting coinciding alongside
the announcement of moonlight could
indicate that he is playing the
character there is actually another
rumor floating about that the Game of
Thrones star will be playing none other
than Wolverine in the x-men universe
reboot Harrington would really fit the
part I think and with the Russo brothers
saying that they'd be interested in
directing a Wolverine solo movie this
could be the first domino that helps to
open up the x-men characters to the MCU
it's definitely something I'd love to
see and I think this lineup is
incredible
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the upcoming shows and which one
you're most excited for leave your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the report that
spider-man is back in the MCU which
would be linked at the end I go over the
apparent new deal between Disney and
Sony and also give my thoughts on it
I'll also be covering everything Marvel
related all weekend from d23 so make
sure you stay locked at the channel for
all the major updates if you want to
come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you